Wow hello everyone and welcome back to
Monday melee yeah yeah guys it's been
two weeks thank you for joining us it's
been too long
Beth how was your last two weeks no one
cares ah Jason O'Malley over here how
was your last two weeks great that's the
right answer
Oh welcome everyone thank you for
joining us uh
Jace good to see you what's up uh lol
someone actually how's it going how's it
going he makes that chat bigger we do
these ailing eyes these old ailing eyes
today we're gonna be playing a little
indie game called the fall I'm very
excited because you know we like to
support indie games our pals the people
out there working in the mines make it
making the games Jack Reacher what's
going on climb climb max Amit Samara
how's it going smile more what's up
what's up
Chewbacca's dad good to see you Barbados
that's right that's right that's right
but we're not we're in California which
is currently a desert like Mad Max so
today we're gonna play the fall so let's
get into it
let's do brightness adjustment you know
I was like to make things as bright as
possible that's right I don't play this
this stuff where it's like ooh let's see
let in the shadows what something like
no like make it as bright as possible
let's do it
I love it oh hey Tasha's ghost is not
hosting us for one viewer Thank You
Tasha's ghost and just to let you guys
know this might be TMI but I have to
mosquito bites on my leg right here and
they are driving me bananas
so if I'm itchy that's right all right
so so far there's a guy falling to earth
ooh and he's got a glowing face so
apparently Daft Punk here is uh it's
gonna be a lot of Daft Punk jokes today
whoa
I love it I think this game I was
reading a little bit about it I think
this game is
about a suit I think we're actually like
a space like a smart spacesuit and the
guy is like passed out inside but you
pick because you really like the Martian
this sort of did like the Martian that's
a great book great book read it Andy
weir
right Andy where it's fantastic they're
making a movie of it with Matt Damon the
frame is moving that's right
crazy hanky the frame is moving because
we look it's a pretty sexy voice yeah is
that our voice that wasn't Cortana yeah
it's like Cortana's mom it's like it's
like it's just a sylph the Cortana
I'd like to f alright sorry hello
Galvatron how's it going alright we need
to look around here
a point of interest trail of blood and
broken glass something was dragged
through here all right the tunnel
created for my impact I can see stars in
the distance I'm approximate great just
do it that's good just just look just
locate the facilities don't tell me
about it
also why if the pilots unresponsive why
and I and that's my voice that's our
voice why are we talking out loud a
shady fridge I believe has a show on
like The Learning Channel or something
that's about like escape the room you
know like that stuff
that's right yeah Jordan remote I by the
way not to brag but I'm about to brag
I'm the only person to ever do escape
the room New York and do it by myself
and get out and escape the room only
person to ever do it it's pretty great
that's pretty great in just kind of
so guys if you I am the guy you know we
always talk about there's an empanada
apocalypse like what we would do what
would you do I would be I would be the
height the person that was hot just
hiding no you would be you'd be the
archivist and food the candy all right
fair enough I learned that I would be
the escape artist I'd be able to get us
out of like I'd be able to like get us
out of any any jam you know what I'm
saying also ultimate intent says I love
escape dream games although I suck at it
they're tough man you don't have the
mind for it yeah see the thing is and
Ayana said I think video games have
helped me with that
a steady drip of blood should we stand
under the blood let's stand under the
blood you guys want to stand up blood
shower
let it rain on us rain blood Slayers
best best song by the way oh that's what
it's called waffle tarts thank you it's
called jimmy pardo race to escape that's
right we could go backwards too so so
far we're playing the fall this is kind
of a fun move I can just kind of whoa
whoops I should have been shining my
light around like a crazy person just
doing don't tell me about it
uh something more fun than looking at
operating parameters I do like the kind
of 80s aesthetic though yeah must not
represent reality must be obedient must
protect active pilot operator well can
we upgrade screen here you can choose
the size through different abilities
press the cross button I appreciate that
they called the cross button an
antimatter shield it restricted motion
accelerator health monitor damaged ten
bucks says this guy is dead in the suit
an organic superior officer is required
to permit access yeah there was a dog
that killed me for a really long time oh
yeah by the way I started I started my
own twitch it's a twitch TV slash Erin
Blair and yeah there was a die that
killed me over and over and over and
over
and yeah I am not great with pets I know
I think they don't really care for you
yeah pets don't care for me either
exactly ultra intense how do we get in
here Oh a security panel so this is a
security panel so we got to find a Power
Cell okay I can't do anything crazy
Henke you wish ah you were my pet no you
don't I don't take good care of pets I
would just let you die are you just
praying for death is that we're talking
about if so that's a different
conversation wait we need to find oh I
see we got a oh wait we have to turn on
our camouflage to get by this that's
what it is
alright let's go to our operating
parameters how do we permit access
you know what I wonder if we can go
under the blood this is kind of gross
but can we go under the blood here and
have that dead turn on our thing what do
you think about that Yeah right go under
the blood no hey Matt motto
double-oh-seven 87 we try the game
called Feist it's very good I will try
the game called Feist thank you I'll say
yeah Chewbacca's dad makes a good point
I don't do very well with aliens either
I got really scared we played alien
isolation on Saturday I got incredibly
frightened it's very scary it's very
late at night I get scared late at night
anyway Jase use this latest software in
the world mix game retro yeah exactly
all right how do we do how do we get by
what's this
so far we've come to the first we've
come to the first puzzle and I can't get
past it so this is gonna be tough what
does this say yeah I know it's blocking
access to the elevator how do we turn on
our any buttons I'm just gonna mash all
the buttons when in doubt has anybody
played this game you guys who wants to
SWAT watch me walk around this part
jet-fuel Lord what's up how's it going
man welcome back or woman maybe you're a
girl Wow snap well burned well burned
fawful that's right search the left
somebody says alright yeah yeah I mean
you don't have to help me but it's gonna
be a long game oh here we go
I can network with this cloaking pattern
a simple winch it's holding up while I
can't get up there alright maybe I can
network it with it
I'll hold the r-1 button interact here
we go ooh
now of course right man every time I'm
in a sentient suit I'm trying to use my
clicking mechanism to interact it oh it
never works always the case
24/7 368 mm you need to travel towards
the Northern Star travelers the Northern
Star
try searching across I think there is
something there yeah I'm searching the
cross yell cancel network interface
disabled do I need to like enable my we
go into my operating parameters real
quick no boy no burqa interface
restricted hmm all right jet fuel Lord
yes I still do stuff with code in yes
we're working we're work we're gonna
shoot some stuff either this week or
next week for the next clueless gamer
I'm very excited all right well what
does this thing say here it's blocking
my view of what this says what's that
thing on the room what does that say
I cannot alright interesting wait a
second
go under the motion sentence and sensor
oh I see oh I see go under the motion
sensor maybe try creeping through the
beam but stop moving when the beam
covers we did we did that yeah bye just
stay still is it gonna turn back on do
we think were you close when you chose
the fall correct
I'm always clueless that's how it goes
Lulla Fon hey what's up I love it
oh where I started go back to where I
started alright go back over there doo
doo doo did it did you it's always good
gettin cardio in these games you know
okay what's this interact there we go
this may be useful something that's not
gonna tell me what it is great I just
picked up something
perfect I didn't realize we could
interact with all these points that's
kind of cool
wait what's this there's a new thing
here a micro wrench oh that's what I
picked up got it
we got a hand
sweet mad sweet exactly blaze dream but
with Beth and random people asking where
coordinates exactly and earlier in the
day
Hey look now we have a hand check this
out watch this I got a hand so I'm gonna
interact with this thing a robotic arm
pride upping it like this Bing nailed it
all right so now what do we do what did
I just get so maybe I can interact using
the security card nope
well I got the security Carboni elevator
I think this will work this game is all
about like shoving random things into
random things aren't everyday progress
ah locust says give yourself a hand
exactly pretty good you'll pat on the
back so so far I've got a robotic back
scratcher a keycard I can't get my
camouflage thing to work what if this is
the entire game is just this passage
it's like PT but like a side scroller
oh yeah you're right I should use the
winch I can't no man hey let's go back
yeah Jake's Cortana must get hung over
Master Chief home exactly so oh yeah you
just passed out
see I can't get up there there's so much
blood over here nope nope nope this oh
wait it's just a dude wait this is a
cloaked guy who's been crucified on this
thing oh man this game is way darker
than I thought
well let's uncloak this crucified guy
we've been over here blue the funds of
it let's see it snacks out I think the
funniest person in twitch I should get
offered a your writer for Conan okay
great idea I'll use all my power which
is zero to make that happen
wait a second we can go to the left ah
man I don't even notice that all right
cool there's a pool down there we can
here we go
the whole time we can just gone to the
left that's ridiculous oh now you tell
us
yeah thanks Chet oh yeah you could
always go to the left
yeah thanks Patti thanks for not helping
there's the worst old metal pan okay who
has more power on Conan Aaron her bed oh
for sure
death controls the site I control this
guy and we all know how this guy's doing
very good hey we got the security card
let's use it you know good thing Mike I
was like in real life my face lit up
like this because I never need to use my
cell phone is like as a flashlight hey
maybe there's something I can hit with
an old metal pan hmm what do you think
should we acquire some data this is by
the way me at the bar girls like hey how
are you I'm like are you standard
greeting and require data acquired data
yeah in your face deep purposing mmm all
right let's just add our primary
function what do we think should we
stand our primary foot tell us what to
do should we deny access issue defensive
warning I think I'm bad at video games
though such a people-pleaser I'd be like
oh you would you like that here you go
yeah the Jos room says you wouldn't be
popular movie theaters there with my lit
up face you're right you're right Jase
you're right though in LA I could get an
easy flashlight facelift yeah what
should I do
[Music]
game audio is really low it says
disengage what should I say issue
defensive warning alright whatever the
next one you look at is disengage
disengage all right we're disengaging
you guys tell us to disengage this is
your fault if we get killed great thanks
chat alright I must state my primary
function they can't they drink too much
oh no we just got neural formatted I
hate that what a terrible way to start
the week a Nero formatted I hate that I
like that imminent networks we required
oh my god operators great updated oh
wait a second oh there we go there we go
now we got our network interface [ __ ]
oh you shouldn't in network interface me
baby coming at you
yeah let's where's the punch button
you just keep it on your hand yeah well
they are Network oh oh yeah oh do we
network the [ __ ] out of them up top yeah
love that yeah you've been networked
[ __ ]
Detroit is gone there's no side of it
yeah we did our part okay can I get the
old metal pan and just beat him up oh
well there's a whole wall there oh we're
inside of a building that's good to know
I just turns out that we're just like
Chuckie Cheese and one of these cheap VR
games all right let's go back down now
we can network with stuff great let's
get out boom yeah Jase yeah right now we
can hack his facebook and look at all
these pictures so many words I don't
understand
Oh God Lulu [ __ ] believe you should all
play Cabela's African safari okay
Cabela's is a big sports trip you guys
ever been to Cabela's it's crazy there's
one in Monroe Michigan where my
grandparents are from and there's some
lights back there and it's got like a
mountain inside like covered in
crossbows and all these like animals
instead it's like I don't think they
wouldn't appreciate that I mean it's
more of like a giant display I think but
you could I mean you could climb the
mountain and then get like alright let's
and they get like grab a crossbow or
something my parents
good mileage it cuz you crave that
mineral I never seen that thing that
cream that mineral no that's a meme you
guys haven't you seen the cream that
mineral no god what's happening yeah
he's been crucified
uh let's acquire data you sound hot
should we go on a date
data data 8 it's pretty good yeah I saw
that
Japan tea I saw that guy skulking in the
background oh you mean the crucifiers
Hey wow this is Jordan I get along
perfectly
Yeah right this is yeah you're
irrelevant can I get you a drink you are
irrelevant come on you guys this is like
what it's gonna be in the future but
this is where iPhones are going we all
know that right it starts with the
iPhone then it moves to the watch then
it moves to the I sleeve then it moves
to the I shirt then it's this thing and
it's to a series talking to each other
while we're passed out and dead you're
the dead one on the past that one yeah
and our suits you know that's all it is
that's like please explain your
Instagram parameters
so it's gonna be yeah there we go
snipe what's exciting what's exciting 11
years in the waiting
oh yeah oh yeah yeah we've got that
Bryan Russell's on the show tomorrow
we're premiering the Deadpool trailer
cool
that's right let's get this gun and he
actually touched great so we're like on
a vampire planet ooh here we go yeah why
don't you let me use my oh wow well hey
we got a friend now it's pretty excited
yeah it's gonna be the full trailer
tomorrow
very excited Ryan Reynolds is a really
cool dude and they're really nice for
letting us do that also tomorrow this is
kind of exciting because we're showing
the Deadpool trailer we're actually
changing the rating of our show for one
night so we can show the trailer
yeah we're changing tomorrow's episode
of Conan will be tv-ma
literally because we're premiering the
Deadpool trailer how cool is that really
very cool
so make sure you guys tune in tomorrow
night and have any small children leave
the room yes sometimes children need to
see the brutalities and the comedy of
life yeah this is the time maybe your
kid grows up
yeah maybe yes it's fun yeah it's like
Tommy stay in the room you need to see
something exactly instead of telling
your kids about the birds and the bees
just let them watch the Deadpool trailer
back
all right here we go camouflage system
still restricted can I use the pan
wait maybe I can use the pan to stop up
some of this blood what about that let's
see if when you put it in the pit oh we
can oh my god what is going on
we're collecting blood I did not think
this game would be what are we doing
this blush lure out the animal a crack
in the floor wait where is the crack in
the floor Russ K Miller exactly finally
you get to become a man by watching the
blood pool trailer Dead Pool sorry yeah
this is the blood pool yeah
can we network with this No
can we put the pan of blood here what's
this here
where's their crack in the floor we can
lure out this animal well yeah
blood pool 2016 oh there's the animal
wait shut
can I put can I put the blood thing
somewhere can I go down it's just gonna
take me up right nope
I don't want to go up
we give CSG oh we're gonna well the
clueless camera probably the next couple
weeks
because I think we're gonna shoot one
very soon blood pool hashtag blood pool
we're looking for a crack in the floor
if anyone sees a crack in the floor let
me know what's this so the guy got
attacked cuz he was dragged through here
so the guy got attacked and then was
dragged over here small crack in the
floors when we're looking for hey buddy
how you doing not good okay cool
sounds good all right and this thing is
gonna go off
this has got to be like the end of the
level here so let's see everyone keeps
saying start the lift is that what
you're trying to start the lift I did
start the whip and start the lift to the
right oh I can jump off the lift I see I
see it's just by the way exactly how I
walk when I'm hungover it's like Oh
exactly
just like my brain the part that
controls your place to pan you might be
able to go under the elevator yeah but
what do I place
I can't just place the pan down I need
to do it one of these little points
[Music]
let's go down whoo there we go you know
it seems kind of dumb that my whole face
lights up but I also need a flashlight
oh it's this area I can't wait for this
little animal to smash me oh here we go
whoa
I guess they hate robots good thing I'm
on this planet nope just looking for
some place to set down my blood pan no
big deal you know I think we're all
looking for a blood test here we go here
we go there we go find the blood pan
setting place yeah I mean it's my giant
light-up flashlight face look at this
little guy yeah buddy buddy buddy buddy
yeah get out all right I'm gonna try to
network with it so wait now I'm just
gonna go back up
do we think I'd go back up or I just
come over here their days Hey
hey took my blood pan hiya dick
dammit and I don't even have the pan
anymore uh the rats could use the blood
fills up on the retreat Oh use the
network I'd see I see Jeff I just played
this game yeah she's on point
shady fridges on point whoops well now
what
I lost my pan took my pan guys yeah
blank light sad Bulls sad boys no more
pan is that Stephen yeah exactly
oh I see oh it still comes out you still
have the pan
I saw the pan JC feed man said we have
the pan we don't have to pay anymore
you guys are crazy there's no more pan
wait it's coming out
so what let's see that's right yeah
sorry kids Fink's I'm sorry I didn't
disappoint you know Conan O'Brien just
this dork thanks for logging in though
and calling me a dork I do appreciate
like we go to work every day we're like
we do bummer
yeah it's a bummer it's a bummer I am a
dork though that's true I got into a
very serious discussion about bit rates
earlier I'm not even kidding but I
wanted like you didn't lose a pan you
were the panel the pan is right here you
never lie there was no pan no one else
saw a pan you just saw pen all right how
do we get this how do i network with the
gun so maybe I should kind of walk over
here then kind of sneak back you think
I'm gonna walk back here then kind of
sneak back but I need to turn on the
light to be able to interact with
anybody
Dork fest yeah kid Sphinx no where I'm
not at all not at all involved with
Conan O'Brien or his show in any way
this is just we just loved Team Coco
this is just a tribute to TV that's
right in no way are we related to
counter to Brock
we're just fans of the fandom yeah we're
just yeah we're just fans of the fandom
kid snakes do you have any anything to
say about how I could get the gun away
from this animal there are three people
in this room the creepers over there
crawling all for us and trying to mate
with it I can't crawl on all fours and
try to mate with it although I would
like to here we go got it can i network
it with it and shoot this thing oh I did
wow that's pretty good
can I pick the gun up or we're just
gonna what are we doing
boom wow that's pretty good
talk about gun safety all right have a
working weapon can I just go shoot stuff
now it's the deal our to button to fire
time right stick to aim right stick dang
whoa damn push down the right stick
laser sight oh cool all right
hey guys disco nobody move boop boop
boop boop all right have this this is
actually a dr. pepper oh Jesus oh no you
know what I'm gonna say hello don't
engage you dick although one dinner
cover okay
[Music]
this is like this is like headshot
hashtag blood pool what's up badass we
are there other guys here
and
[Music]
oh I just got hit
and this gun blows
[Music]
pop-up
Jesus I got killed what last checkpoint
I've got a pan and they're blended
attack know what was the last checkpoint
oh it's where we got the gun okay that's
all been alright no worries yeah yeah
did I comply it I know how this ends
ends it a headshot yeah you have no
problem yeah let's get a done son
enough of this
[Music]
oh my figs cracked that's a bummer it
comes back on a mattock oh there we go
I scavenged these guys are like touch
them inappropriately
yeah snipe yes if that that is gonna
take that the robot voice is gonna take
us into the year 2000 all the way and so
far I don't know which member of Daft
Punk I am but I'm a badass how do we get
back across this thing I guess we just
jump now that I've got a gun can I just
go shoot this other machine and destroy
it
Oh a takedown Erdos obviously I
interviewed you never charge around how
do I do that to take down an enemy from
behind I know what that means
oh damn I got a robot knife that's
pretty cool wait do I take some of the
energy oh I see
this game just got way cooler
nope I'm the fizeau I'm the third DAP
pug member they went their own way to
pursue a career in blood and the blood
pan business is booming by the way just
kills me yeah exactly
hello can i interests into one pan can I
shoot this thing
nope can I shoot that gun nope and
interact with this at all because I
don't have a pop I'm looking for a Power
Cell probably right Fantomex debt yeah
this is like Robo limbo limbo otherwise
a great game
this is pretty great things have kind of
picked up a little bit from the blood
pan days and the wandering or out the
blood pan
no no we gotta get a look around should
we go back down that cavern maybe lol
someone actually thank you for taking
time out of your busy instagram-stalking
to come see us duly appreciate it okay
does anyone else think you look like you
look like Rick from Rick and Morty do
you get that reckon no man you dicks
Rick and Morty
what am i a dumb dick the answer is yes
hashtag dumb dick I'm gonna go up here I
think there was something upstairs that
out I liked that we missed let's go back
upstairs
death to Robo Jesus mega fer yes mega
Frank West nailed it this is exactly
Robocop limo huh you nailed it this is
exactly what it is it's if Robocop is in
the game limbo but there's less giant
spiders in this game so far
drones gone
I can't network with that dumb dick
that's right
I am a dumb dick for sure
hashtag flashlight face also the thing
is I guess it would be great to it you
know like having a flashlight face think
of all the great things you do can read
at night easy to put on your flat just
turn your flashlight face looking for
keys really easy but where's the light
what do you mean like reflect it back
into you can you just like shut it off
oh can you shut it up I don't know but
that would how would never you sleep I
don't know oh no I oh you're right sorry
ultimate intense thank you I haven't
networked with the Crucified guy yet I
mean with the box above it I'm gonna do
that right now so you can blind people
with your yeah be great to take photos
it looks like nice even lighting you
know so really that's the secret I'm it
looked like you having good skin right
do you guys see those new khloe
kardashian photos by the way what's
going on man how could you miss him so
crazy
all right let's network with it oh wait
yeah we already did oh wait no up here I
think wait can I shoot this though maybe
I could shoot this thing there we go
whoo hello how are we doing here let see
ah we can remove the Power Cell which is
gonna get us the thing sorry buddy
sorry buddy Specter boy that is rough by
the way see ya no man kill my only
friend
we are harsh like 2001 days someone's
asking Karen do you talk while you're
gaming at home when you're alone just
for practice I do I do
oh my god don't dick suck I do it's a
lot of swears it's mostly swears oh cool
I uh great so now the guns gonna shoot
me so I got that going for me really
glad I put this power cell in here yes
this is awesome tonight
Jesus maybe I can network with this
thing oh man I just totally screwed
myself
wait now this thing's gonna shoot me run
into it great oh I love it I have to I
have to make my I have to put myself in
danger to get the if this guy was awake
he could just hook me up here this is
dumb let's do it camo me baby enable it
let's go well let's go cloaked
yeah except for the giant light on my
face for clothes okay let's back out of
the sensor
have Jesus a little too close to like
that
nothing to see here
except a giant bright faceplate no big
deal that's pretty fun alright let's go
upstairs what what ah there we go
yeah Jase I don't know what's the point
of having a human feels ten times better
than him I don't know but then again we
don't know how good the human is I don't
know what allegory
what is it allegory isn't that
allegories it's telling it's a it's like
a metaphor but like for a story
there's no allegory here this is just
this is literally the robot the suit
telling itself dude it's okay fine
you're gonna be okay we did a good job
we did a good job we log entry deleted
what does that mean what's this a Depot
we're at a Home Depot Houston 50 minutes
to do section one yeah it did yeah I did
were dumb but 49 of those minutes were
just playing around the bull of blood
pants Oh
it's a great time oh it's this guy let's
just kill him yeah I use camouflage I'd
rather just shoot them if we just go
slow we can just kill him all his it
just better to kill them or am i right
why wouldn't we want to kill them we
have unlimited ammo leaving a trail of
dead in my wake how did the follows an
allegory of Conan's leg yeah the Falls
an allegory
I'm not what what do you think the fall
is an allegory of GTV man wrote in a
story poem or picture that can be
interpreted to reveal a hidden meeting
typically a moral or political so Apple
like suits are coming or something what
would be what what could possibly be the
allegory of this suit that we've created
that aren't what about this that our to
our children the next stage of human
evolution is that are actually what we
create what about that what the machine
that's an arthur c clarke that yeah that
that the kid spanks i'm at i am a dork
arthur c clarke once said i think that
that the next David should human
evolution will not be human but the
machines that we create more destroyed
robots deep purposing got it so maybe
I'm a deep purposed robot I'm not
supposed to be here what it looks like
this is exactly like what a future IKEA
I feel like is gonna look like
arthur c clarke also said any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic which is
kind of cool
can i network with it though this game
you never got against guys ever hear
about will it blend this game is all
like will it network that's the whole
point can't interact a face can't
network with it
what else is there to do here it's a lot
of shining your flashlight around I'm
not so hot on that fizeau
well played didn't it didn't have R to
create the Appleseed that's true a bunch
of fruits there bunch of fruits and they
created the grape suit further loom
really beat Apple to the punch I hope
they trademark the apples yeah they
should also do the eye suit Oh someone
said the allegory is the next stage of
human evolution as humans mating with
iPhone that's shoe so the face is an LED
so that's like the iPhone arterial I get
it just jump up here AI think a lot of
people have close relations with their
phones it's only making them yeah I
would not mate with my android phone
though yeah he's gonna bump into me Wow
look at this he doesn't notice the giant
faceplate right in the back there's an
allegory for you I stab you in the back
fellow robot kenneth's robots just come
together
this guy looks like a bigger robot than
the other ones right whoops didn't
notice that gun huh
I can't shoot him Oh weird
Oh what's happening cuz he's like like
sideways or whatever I don't understand
can he not see me oh oh he's like
sleeping
he's like robot sleeping yeah they
should turn off his faceplate he's
wasting valuable energy it's like people
who leave their Bluetooth on all the
time
a-holes turn off the Bluetooth on your
phone what's wrong yeah go be with an
Eskimo gamer next couple weeks next
couple weeks I think we're shooting
I think we're shooting one next week
it's my guess so probably on the week
after that is my guess oh hey speaker
microphone and a number-pad
make some beats can we make some dope
beats yeah beats by robo dre
I'm just in like these robots office
this is like a future IKEA we're just in
the basement of IKEA we're gonna see a
bunch of Robo homes yeah we're gonna see
a bunch of like internet flim flam's
about what repeat options this is what I
well even in the future they had they
have like these
Robo menus okay okay yeah I've met some
your droids who can aid with other tasks
like killing you
here's some other tasks like murdering
you making you dead
let's do I don't remember what the
numbers were but let's do - probably
business hours right this happens what I
call this happens when I call Time
Warner every single time let's record a
message oh no don't say this don't give
away just ply
whoa mark gruba
this robot is a dumb dick for sure this
is pretty cool G says a magic putting
together two robots as IKEA furniture
and treasures yeah I can its horrifying
it took me almost an hour to get past
the first level I don't think I could
put together one of these robots that's
really friendly boy we got the chat we
got Chatty Cathy here yeah this dude at
the bar uh what are we doing here so
what do you do it yeah hey so what's up
hey
my human inside is dying cool like what
are you up to these days that's so cool
like do you hang out here her like yeah
my humans dying oh you want some chicken
what's your inator tell us what to do
guys requests human assistance ascertain
location or seek medical that's right
what do we do somebody said ultimate
intent seek medical okay yeah I don't
want to go out with you oh my god how
about dumb dick how about dumb dick tell
me how about the name is dick dumb dick
[Music]
now this guy hey quick cock-blocking me
dude wow this a-hole oh now we're in a
fight this is like a roommate fight did
you do the dishes is this true like yeah
can't we all just get along wait a
second hey hey dick whoa this guy looks
like a guy from Boardwalk Empire with
the half face oh man I got a simpler
task how about me shooting I already get
yeah exactly
oh this can't be good don't think I'm
gonna present my holes and put out here
look my place is not in the kitchen okay
this you know this Abel it's gotten a
lot of outdated thoughts about female
robot body suits here you know come on
what's that we don't even probably earn
the same amount as male robo suits this
is ridiculous
should I just here's the thickness in
this this is becoming allegorical by
this is actually very allegorical about
women's rights as a feminist I can't
affirm functionality here I got to deny
compliance yeah I'm a combat suit [ __ ]
you want to see you want to see what my
suits made for I look cute
oh I'm so scared yeah yeah now what's up
can't see me yeah exactly
ha ha hey your plan didn't work did it
dumb dick I can't shoot him whatever oh
you know what I have to do I think wait
can I
so wait I need to get this guy awake
again and kill him I think right no
don't pretend that you care about me
here's one a robo job alright thank you
the Communists alright ascertain attack
protocol let's do it yeah just as I
won't go out with you
yeah I gave you my quantum signature now
just leave me alone you know I don't
agree with that when you go to the right
male financers oh my God he's
mansplaining stuff this is crazy
this game is great by the way you're
just joining us for playing the fall
which is actually turned into quite
allegory but yeah it's an allegory about
it yeah comedies even feminism it's
actually really great I'm really
enjoying this all right
disengage yeah that's right boom
are we gonna go over and kill this guy
but I can't you know what won't let me
do anything I can't all right let's go
over the right there say I might find
answers on the right here oh here we go
nope nope so maybe I should go should we
interact with this and then go to the
right maybe maybe cuz maybe it up if I
gotta kill this guy Chewbacca is dead
just follow this instruction one zero
one one zero one zero one zero robot has
a Cylon that's right that's right these
music what's up just comply ultimate
intent says why no oh yeah whatever you
know what you're still part of the
system you could quit anytime you want
it to buddy don't give me that crap yes
man following orders oh yeah yeah a lot
of a lot of bad stuff has been done in
the name of following orders son of a
[ __ ]
oh it doesn't does it you know I'm not
just gonna give up my quantum signature
all willy-nilly anymore I think I've
learned my lesson you know what I'm
saying
this regulation is your only way out I
don't believe that all right
so I should shoot that thing above him
there we go it is this wait wait wait
oh there we go oh you know it now when
he comes out he's gonna get zapped
that's what it is that's what it is I
suppose also I could come on out pal I'm
not I'm not complying so yeah yeah yep
yeah I'm fine I'm fine go ahead go ahead
this robot it's so creepy I hate this
guy thanks Batman
you're awesome - denied complying - Oh a
perfect house circuit dude you bro a but
see I'm gonna get up there and just pop
pop pop there we go
baking cookies just like grandma's trip
this is crazy
Oh deny compliance yeah I'm a
military-grade war machine the way this
is the worst birthday ever
oh yeah actually the worst birthday ever
I would just leave immediately if I was
a woman robot combat war machine that
would be like I'm out of here
all right prepare to be zapped mofo
didn't even get zapped maybe I need to
do something with the thing that fell
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
now I guess it's got it oh my god sorry
alright it's the last time although I do
want to hear with this misogynistic
a-hole yeah yeah we know we know we know
we know we know we know this is
horrifying you're dumb you're dumb we
hate you didn't I comply it's my
favorite part of this game so far
[Music]
use it open that door let me out of here
this is what a shady French said you can
interact with it enables you to head
through the previously locked door to
the right yep yep we go alright let's
look around oh is this your previous
dates haha exactly well your conquest
yes yeah how's your conquest going you
dick
[Music]
what is it oh my god this is horrifying
si don't let the adult let creepy robots
buy you Robo drinks
[Music]
Oh human corpse oh well there's some
security pieces here I think we should
take some how can we take them
this ceiling has something for us what
do we do next gang yeah tell us where to
go next everybody I really want to get
revenge on this really creepy man robot
Oh leave this what is that can I shoot
it
I feel like I don't want this thing to
see me right or do I go back and talk to
the administrator again oh now that is
data Human Bondage
Oh got it okay thanks shady fridge
What's Up sir pedra Elvis acquire data
bodies oh this is gonna be great
tell me about some bodies creepazoid
yeah what have you been up to someone's
couch yeah what did you do oh people I'm
sorry too are people denying compliance
this guy don't try to make a rhyme huh
I'm not affirming guys no one but I
always trust no one what's that from
Oh x-files I want to believe everything
she was just a firm compliance I don't
want to do it but sometimes you got to
lie to get out of situations by your own
risk
Mitch Blackman thank you I don't want a
firm compliance I don't want to do it
it's just wrong but we're supposed to
get him to follow us
maybe we should just lie to this do you
know douchebags sometimes when you lie
to douchebags like yeah yeah cool no
problem yeah and then you just leave
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah Pam
I'm gonna go to the bathroom I'll be
right back and you just knew Bert go
home Netflix bed go to sleep get the
option to submit yourself for evaluation
under the lip okay so we should have fun
yeah all right let's do it
we're affirming compliance only to this
guy not to ourselves we just want to
make it clear before we do this we're
not complying sounds excited gross right
to the elevator
all right not happy about this we got to
do it man
I did here with a lone gunman
I'm excited they're coming back lone
gunman are gonna be in your kumail's in
the new axe yeah Kamel Nanjiani a good
friend of ours too this is crazy this is
totally an allegory by the way take it
back yeah but allegory I just still go
back downstairs probably we don't want
to go up sorry now we're back downstairs
oh no we're going upstairs what's
upstairs I just totally denied you're
compliant there's mushrooms up here
whoa this is crazy
an ancient vehicle so all so mankind is
all dead and now it's all run by
Morlocks and weird this is on Steam
another wooden person this child is
covered in fungus this game is super
creepy I think we got to go back
downstairs oh it's another crazy thing
were they were they crucify people
yeah but there's blood on it
no no Jesus you know I'm gonna go
downstairs first I think city bones 22
says The Last of Us sequel exactly it's
the last of a sequel with the robot with
a flashlight face
what's up Longhorn how's it going thanks
for joining us if you guys are just
joining us from playing the fall which
has turned into quite a crazy game in
the beginning what fans and blood pan we
had a blood pan we filled with blood of
the whole thing but now stuffs got
really creepy and the plot has thickened
plastic shoe covers ladies my
maintenance crews to keep the carpet
clean interact with I'm a war machine
and I'll shoot you right in the face how
about that great
I want to shoot you so bad oh god what's
this here oh it's our creepy creepazoid
this is crazy this is my nightmare by
the way bypass request help yeah forget
that we're dissipating I'll be back this
is super creepy doll oh this may suffice
to beautify here the room computer paper
got it
everything about that buddy am I just
making this room beautiful or all real
look I'm already thinking in the way
they want button this is awful that
smart
yes we take both scanners a ghoulish
wooden family is seated on a wooden
table why did you take the flowers I
don't know why because we're on to
beautify the place yeah I'm supposed to
be beautifying things nothing here is
functional okay let's talk to our creepy
stalker slansky world let's go upstairs
I'm a war machine I made to kill someone
said that we should grab a shoe box by
the front door and then head upstairs
okay not sure the shoe box sounds
important yeah I thought we'd grab it I
think I have I have I did grab a shoe
buffer yeah man just give me more things
to shoot bro I'm not gonna talk to my
creepy dude oh wow cool so they have
crucified people in here yeah I love it
yeah you're gonna have to beautify our
home but please leave the Crucified
human alone all right
what holiday is it in Canada today more
of a tall it's not a holiday how about a
bullet to the crotch that big good
that's I think they wanna like that this
is insane
I'm a war machine acquire data yeah what
did you do did they reject your advances
maybe yep I knew it it rejected this guy
[Music]
threatened me yeah bring it
it's BC day these British Columbia ring
is happy British Columbia day hey do you
hate baby do you like bullets New
Brunswick oh wait not British Columbia
Oh God
Oh God can't you see my shirt can't you
look at this I don't care about taking
care of a baby it's the worst
hello baby how are you I guess I need
something from a slot honey did that
work well I shot it stop crying I think
that worked great all right cool perfect
done I think we're done here we got to
find something Oh what's this nice hairs
Musti oh yeah maybe the flowers go in
the baby babies thing babies eat flowers
right I don't know anything about babies
or flowers oh there's no reason to
remove them that's where they're
supposed to go and there's nothing to
interact with here let's look around
some more
it's raining like the shoe cover on the
scanner in you oh here's a large
industrial tube oh wait let's put the
thing in here empty glass jar wait what
did you say I should you go to the
bedroom use the shoe cover on the
scanner Oh got it got it got it all
right
remind me to never trust you with my kid
yeah I'm not available for babysitting
everyone this should be obvious shoot
cover nope doesn't work whoever said
that horse I'm out in the chat you're
dumb you dumb doesn't work there's
nothing else in here okay I'd like tear
a piece off this guy or something and
use it as a palm print
there's nothing else up here I don't
think it seems like it's lighting up for
a second now the ceiling scanner this
scanner nope
oh-oh-oh-oh maybe put the shook over
over here ah
got it okay cool so now what did that do
exactly so now it doesn't know we're
upstairs Oh got it got it so we covered
the thing that finished see so clean the
room there we go
I love it oh you're so stupid
boom war machine one creepy stalker guy
zero
I've never really there we go I'm Trevor
Holland I can't watch this scrub I know
it's depressing I don't want no scrub
scrub I bring it back get to the kitchen
droid I'll write them in the kitchen yo
hey dude I'm here brah it's gonna
supposed to do here oh my god ridiculous
oh wait wait hold on I beautified this
room let me beautify this room real
quick yep
did it done it processing also he says
this dumb duck says processing well the
rock seasonal color war droid I get to
keep trying no it means I should leave
dumb dick
okay there we go that's what I need to
be against something to be able to do
that yep anybody else wants some still
gonna fire me alright oh my god I'm dead
what you a-holes Jesus I wasn't taking
them seriously cuz I got so angry at the
dumb dick yeah but now we're back oh now
we got her back this way here we go
here we go down the stairs I'm a war
machine dammit I care about the stupid
dick ulis gang groceries is hard yeah
yeah ok I'll return with about 4 robot
heads on my belt
hey what is a she come here
what is this what did this a was
[Music]
guess my shields almost dead there we go
I just keep shooting at this height and
I just probably kill everything go to
the grocery store I need a wire alright
fair enough
looking for a little wire
I would sing Himes wire it seems like
appropriate right now because I'm
looking for a little wire but we don't
have the money for it so came down to
the wire you know should I go upstairs
first I look for this dumb little wire I
know I go to the grocery store man
collapse debris corrosive compound a we
think we'll worried be on the ground but
what do I know
Oh what's this it's mostly intact shook
upstairs do you think I guess we should
go upstairs it's already open all right
in your face
so shared about the wired theme song oh
yeah that's a great by the way the wire
holds up the show okay great so good
she's interacts with the Box interacted
with the box so there's no wires down
over here nope
right right I'll just started following
us on Twitter yay I know this is the man
I don't wear the species I already
looked at that thing more wooden people
this is next level
interesting can you use the shopping
cart without me
I don't think there's a shopping cart
yet we haven't found one mushrooms again
so many shrooms all these shrooms is
making me hungry
no I'm powered
I think we gotta go back down to that
box we're not even supposed to be up
here yet some things on the ceiling in
the wire room no we're we're cutters
there we go
maybe useful tire iron we'll take that
where's it there are many items here in
the sixties interesting interesting
this is the sequel to Mad Men Matthew
winders just like lost his mind is just
like this actually the unresponsive
guy's Don Draper yeah it's like opens up
and it's like that last scene again and
like meditating and then it plays a coke
at back down is where the shopping cart
all right well we got the wire cutter so
I think we can probably cut some wires
off of something here this
good to get dem wire cutters Doh doh-doh
peeps dog dude 84 yeah wouldn't your
house of wax is a great movie very scary
all right so it's our shopping cart
somewhere can I cut a piece off of one
of them one of the white oh here we go
shopping cart nope nope maybe I should
go back up to that truck cause it House
of waxing oh wait what's this glass
plain fragile let's shoot it yeah how
did something fall down god there's
another oh my god we just did this pure
gold
green blood
you know what let's collect some green
blood yeah hashtag blood jar hashtag
blood jar ulcer
oh I want to feed it to one of these
people hey guess what Johnny I know what
you're about to eat green slug blood I
might not be able to make it to uh might
not be able to make the grocery store
but then again you're stupid so don't
worry about it
well alright that's what this war
machine I'm one I'm head [ __ ] in charge
man I'm gonna feed this idiot some
stupid blood I live at the bit maybe we
give the baby the gold coin you want
some blood everybody work it should I
should feed you bloody idiots yeah
exactly blood pools here let's go see if
we can put the gold coin in the baby
thing
yeah baby's like money oh you know what
actually probably gold coin we got to
pay for something other groceries yeah
that's probably gonna happen let's just
make it at the grocery store then we'll
call it a day it's lit somebody said
slurm soda yep no you don't want to do
this drama
slim Saudi I think so I can I use the
gold coin there's a way to alter it ooh
wait should we go maybe we should go up
to the workbench oh and like to use that
and change the gold coin second argh
I'm gonna pound it away I don't think so
it just say maybe there's a way to alter
why would it say that it's our favorite
creeper creeper Zoid yeah yeah exactly
cool request second floor power please
utilize your elevator so I may proceed
oh my god this guy's a tool too you're
an [ __ ] seriously why do you attempt
to emulate human grammar and Technology
yes that's Bob Ford
that's depressed be yourself man why
you're here
head ridin into the building at the end
here you'll find a work clothes into a
little productive wire if I were
malfunctioning I would have been sent to
a military
facility not domestically in your face
[Music]
yeah we fell from the sky the games
called the fall for goodness sakes oh
well well you're stupid here we go he's
trying to fit in like oh yeah got to be
yourself man
luckily I don't need a light because my
face is so bright perfect
nailed it pounded it
she want to get in the grocery store
that's all I want to do in my life
fandom XF that's why this is called the
five not the game just took place during
autumn haha double meaning double
meaning or during the fall of man yeah
yeah yeah the fall of man yeah yeah I
wonder I wonder what kind of kind of guy
our pilot is you think he's a nice guy
or think he's kind of like a douche but
he's pretty cool maybe that's like the
twist is at the end it turns out he's
like a jerk and then like we gained
sentience or whatever you know and
they're like we have to we have to
destroy him or like we get like
decommission because we're too smart all
right we did it turn on the power now we
gotta go upstairs
[Music]
that's right
Mitch bla man can't wait to see their
reaction to the ending we're not close
are we
every close to the ending yeah are we
close how close are we to the ending
people have played this it doesn't feel
like we're close we were bad at this
yeah another way another wooden person
was stained over else when you interact
we take the overalls wait I don't
understand
where's the shopping thing so does it
head back downstairs to the grocery
store Oh what all the gold wire [ __ ] I
did that
[Music]
Mitch blobbin not too close but your
speculation is interesting ah yeah
that's right after all this all sleeves
to ourselves well sleeves to our devices
guys our device yeah you know all right
this game is all about if your phone has
feelings your honor I'm saying there's a
great book by the way if you guys like
sci-fi called counting heads I've told
you about that book it's awesome and
it's kind of like it's a little bit like
this it's like in the future like Siri
Siri becomes like a thing called a valet
that everyone wears and everyone kind of
has this personal assistant that you
that you talk to you and it's
fascinating and then it's all about like
them and there's like a murder mystery
it's really great all right all we want
to do it's working correctly how do we
get into the the dead slug up here and
we've got the blood cut again to the
grocery store man how do we do that
where is the grocery store
oh here it is
yeah downstairs more dad how do we get
downstairs seriously where did we go was
that movie Scarlett Johansson ultimate
intense oh yeah her exactly her is like
the romantic comedy version of this well
we've been upstairs all I want to do is
get to the grocery store it's already
open it's working correctly my missing
that is the grocery store this is the
grocery store under the green bleeding
thing Oh
under the green bleeding thing is the
grocery store the shopping cart is by
the grocery what is happening no one
knows who the grocery store is actually
oh it looks like this goes in here right
oh I'll be killed that thing the grocery
store looks like it's close to here
where is it interact with the stove's if
either tell the government let's take it
back the enters a grocery store we did
that or you're in it look at the shelves
oh this is the grocery store oh oh I see
oh this is the grocery store this is a
grocery store here we were in it the
whole time but there's nothing here so I
guess we got the green stuff oh you know
what we should go put the stuff in the
stove the blood our blood jar we should
go put the blood jar in the stove you're
in it the whole time that's true all
right here we go we're gonna go cook
cook up some slug blood Polly I just all
I want to see are these dumb humans eat
this damn it it doesn't work well finish
won't be
I hate talking this collar oh oh I got
your food for you I will return wait I
don't have the food though what was the
what is the food go to the left you get
gives new meaning to the term blood
sausage go to the right
alright beast music we're going to the
right tell us where to go here shoot the
light blood for flour dude the Blitz for
the flower that can't be right
what is this what blood is the food I
know that's what we keep saying have you
got a decaying a head in hand haha oh my
god oh wait where is the corpse guy Oh
upstairs yeah oh maybe we feed the
humans the corpse I will shoot the baby
again don't worry about that I'm gonna
feel oh can we feed the baby the bullet
the slug blood oh yeah let's try it oh
please let this happen it doesn't work
but what if the baby's crying a little
work okay go back to that Mitch blonde
man go back to the grocery store and
shoot just to the left of the light okay
Mitch to be initiate the test and try to
feed it the blood I think it's all
returned we're gonna shoot the left of
the light people are telling us to shoot
to the left of light and that's what
we're gonna do it all I want to do is
feed this family you'll get some body
parts oh here we go
got it let's feed this dumb family some
body parts
oh I hate humans they're the worst I did
the worst way shoot to the left at the
light there's nothing up there but shoot
the corpse that make Fowley
oh here we go
[Music]
well we know what we do with loose
ceiling panels getaway slug yeah take it
I'll be delicate oh my god there's still
a little meat left you know I haven't
had lunch yet I'm very ah Jesus dumb
dicks keeping me from mine yeah whatever
headshot come on out buddy all right
whatever
leave me alone I got to feed this family
some human meat where'd my million
hangry I got your food right here pal
it's a head
a rotting head it's cracked open enjoy
savages good scream yes your foods right
there why did you yep please need it I
[Music]
love it we did it well you know all this
decaying head jockeys may be pretty
hungry so I think we're gonna end the
stream here for today guys thank you so
much for joining us we will see you next
Monday and also go follow me at twitch
TV slash Aaron blare I'll be twitching
later this week for sure you want to get
your fix of more decayed heads and a
bunch of [ __ ] and make sure to watch
tonight
TBS we're back on 11:00 p.m. and
tomorrow night we've got Ryan Reynolds
on and he's debuting the brand-new full
Deadpool trailer and we're making our
show we're changing the rating of our
show for one night literally just to
show the Deadpool trailer so please
don't miss that it's gonna be awesome if
you do miss it
you can see it I'm Team koco.com which
will have the trailer up and all this
other good stuff thank you guys for
joining us this game has been the fall
bet murasky Jase O'Malley we'll see you
guys next Monday bye
[Music]
you